and it isn't just Florida our next guest
predicts upwards of maybe 50 seats
gained for the GOP in the house and as
many as seven in the Senate joining me
now is Newt Gingrich former speaker of
the house and Fox News contributor Newt
um which race that's first of all that
would be an unbelievable just tsunami
for the for the GOP but what race do you
think would most surprise
the Democrats for Republicans to pick up
well I mean it could be Masters in
Arizona could be balduck in New
Hampshire it could be Tiffany Smiley in
Washington state Joe O'Day in Colorado
I'm just sticking with Center races I
think you're going to see Herschel uh
Walker win in Georgia you just had a
great winner on from Florida where the
Republicans in Florida will probably win
the biggest victory for governor and
senator in the history of the state for
the Republican Party
um I think you're going to see Dr Oz win
in Pennsylvania JD Vance is going to win
in Ohio I think Ron Johnson is going to
run away with it and probably the
biggest
Wisconsin Senate victory in modern times
for a republican what what's happening
and you see it everywhere you see it in
the most recent poll in Illinois where
Governor pritzker is now in a very very
close race you see it in Oregon where
the Republican is slightly ahead now uh
every time I turn around I get another
email from my good friend Barry
Castleman in Minnesota just wrote me
that we're now well ahead both for
attorney general and it's slightly ahead
for governor in a race that two weeks
ago we were behind by 10 points and so
there's a tide building across the
country and it's a combination of
inflation uh higher prices for
everything crime uh an uncontrolled
border uh the whole crisis of drugs and
then this nuttiness about I mean they
ask yourself this Lord because I think
it's so crazy how could a White House
two and a half two weeks before an
election schedule a president to sit
down with a Tick-Tock specialist who's
going through a year-long transgender
transformation and have the president
say he is against any rules of any kind
stopping children from getting involved
in in this kind of sex change process
which is a wildly unpopular position but
how could you even schedule it oh
they're bad tells you where the White
House is yeah they're bad I want to show
you something you have to ask yourself
they're crazy Charlie Chris and Ron
DeSantis faced off tonight in the first
and only gubernatorial debate there I
want to play a little bit
over 6 million of our fellow Floridians
have gotten coveted under your
leadership you're the most anti-business
Governor I've ever seen that's time
Congressman Governor yeah except for all
the businesses that are moving down here
and leading the nation in net in
migration focus on the vulnerable
population but make sure you're not
locking down the rest of the people
we've thrived as a result that would not
have happened if Charlie Chris had got
his way and locked down the State of
Florida in July of 2020.
well note another example of what
happens when Democrats actually commit
to debating I mean to say that Ron
DeSantis is anti-business real quick
response
no I'm just going to say think about the
insanity of Charlie Chris saying you're
an anti-business Governor when everybody
in the country understands Florida is
one of the two or three best places in
the country to do business in I mean
Democrats are asking us to ignore our
eyes ignore our ears pretend none of
this is happening and the country's just
too smart for that
and Newt I want to thank you for your
really sweet and very touching it almost
made me ball on air your little
anniversary message that we played the
other night thank you that meant
enormous amount you've done a great job
you're an historically important job I
really appreciate it thank you note hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else